Jim and Michael here at CES 2017 we're
at Adele's suite checking out a crazy
monitor that was actually the first
company to release a 5k monitor and
they've upped the ante by releasing
eight or by announcing an aka monitor
which is actually 16 times as sharp as a
traditional 1080p panel and that's about
30 3.3 million pixels it's not really
for gaming it's more for productivity
but Michael we're standing in front of
it right now what do you think of it you
could tell that the detail is extremely
fine on this product because of the
pixel density but like you mentioned
it's for photography and film production
in terms of its gaming application
hardware isn't exactly there yet in
terms of producing 4k resolution in
games so the jump to aka isn't exactly
meant for gaming but you could tell that
the image quality is definitely there
with pixel density when you're looking
at photos such as the one here on the on
the desktop it's hard to differentiate
between pixels and so you're gonna get
that super fine detail but again it's a
standard 60 Hertz monitor - you're not
gonna get a super high where you press
rate I also mentioned that it takes to
display ports to actually output image
on this resolution just so I'm just so
high that you're gonna require a lot
more power so I mean even the highest
end gaming hardware you're not really
gonna get there with this but also games
aren't going to exactly be native for 8k
they're still trying to get to 4k so
we're gonna it's going to be years down
the line before we see 8k as a game
but to see it here on display is it's a
pretty amazing thing would you say it's
like the best looking monitor you've
ever seen yeah of course I would say
that just just by sheer pixel density
even at 32 inches you know a lot of
1080p displays r32 when you can see it
at 32 inches it's it looks fine but when
you really get up to a get up and close
especially cluttered yeah you can't
really tell so just by virtue of that
it's very fine it's the best monitor
you've seen so far because of the
suspect yeah the resolution is it's
sixteen by nine but the resolution is
seven thousand six eighty by 4320 and I
mean just setting front of it like
normally even with a 4k panel I can make
out the pixels I cannot make out the
pixels here and the thing that Lewis
stands out to me is that this is running
Windows 10 and this the scaling is like
regular native and the icons are just so
tiny like I'm standing right in front of
the monitor and I can't and I can't I
can't even read the time because the
text is just that small yeah and they
also mentioned that they just they did
that on purpose to kind of get the
feeling of how fine and detail the
resolution is of course if you're gonna
use it for a regular desktop stuff you
can just want to scale your icons but it
just shows like how how many pixels are
fit into this bond
yeah and it doesn't come at a cheap
price that's coming out at five thousand
dollars and it's releasing in March so
for more tech coverage stay tuned to
Gamescom